is Hector Bombay and he will be telling
us about time correlated noise in
photonics quantum computation
can you hear me
ok
okay that's for me okay so let me down
directly into the motivation so these
work you up so basically could your city
I mean it could have some practical
applications that mostly clear city for
me so if we want to build a quantum
computer we need q ases eyewear isolated
so they don't go here and that we can
control very precisely maybe we can find
sad Cupid in nature maybe this is some
material that can / 10 plus or maybe we
can catch me engineer settle materials
but even in that is not the case we have
a kind of generic solution for like the
problem of I mean only in a career no
secrets which is fault tolerant okay so
portal and tells you okay you have cute
that are most Eva just not too noisy
when you come from arbitrary complex
quantum optics so the conditions for
this to be true among the conditions are
the fact that not only dinner should be
weak but also should be weakly
correlated in space and that okay this
is important condition so the purpose of
this talk to discuss with rope in some
of these conditions and particular to
consider knowing which arbitrary
relations in time I will be more precise
later as water and in fluid so why I
start I think in all this it was I was
thinking about fabrication pots okay so
you have some quantum device are they
supposed to perform folder and condemn
abating ok so this device has cubes
connection between biscuits and so on
and if it is suffocated perfectly maybe
then so the kids are not so noisy and
then it will be able to compute over now
what happens if would you make it like
some of the qubits are permanently
damaged or some of the links it and give
it some permanently damaged and so on
other devices that will still continue
to perform correctly okay that was my
end of juice tea so there are different
scenario we could consider maybe we know
like where the fabrication pulsar we
could probably like the device not like
that and then maybe read some
flexibility in how we can operate the
device okay so how we interact
classically with it so this will be one
class of problems
I'm pointer is not different kind here
so for today I was curious what will
happen TV for some reason we all know
where the whole tire or maybe they sense
it slowly over time or something like
that and what if you know we cannot
really since the operation of the system
in or not enough ok to deal with that so
go eat the question now this is not
maybe a this is not a very elegant or
mathematically very elegant kind of
stolen but living is that in that kind
of situation do we have very strong
correlations in time for the false ID so
it's wonky we disprove any limits of
course it will be popular dinosaur so
you can think more generally ok what
happens if I have disc an arbitrary
correlations in time for so much so
doing things me to issue of what i mean
by that what is the noise model so i
will be considering a stochastic noise
ok so this is just a dog model that is
very useful to understand fault tolerant
then you can get more sophisticated as
if you're trying something new a good
way to it so in the stochastic noise
models we start from some ideal secret
ok so fixing here so this is already
there faltering a secret and so there
will be different different histories ok
and it's of these features will
correspond to a set of faults in the
system so this case here what you can
see with our specific history where some
of the locations within some of the gate
are faulty so they don't do what we
expected ok so there will be some some
adversity you want ok so kind of work is
worst-case scenario from them on that
chooses which with with which
probability its history of false will
occur and what kind of false will
actually happen in the locations of that
fork ok so we are going to constrain the
power of this alone by important and
some conditions and constraint on the
toilet is for ease of this research so
in the conventional case ok we have
local isocratic now so this is the
in this area of weak correlations in the
space and time so we have our country
quantum circuits applications and then
the condition is that if i take any
number of locations okay some fixed
number of any locations then the
priority that all of them will sail okay
at the same time irrespective of what
happens to the civil cases the produce
this end location field sales is a
smaller than lambda to the end where
lambda is the error okay so in this case
we have occasion to 95 and 5's ability
smaller than lambda squared now we know
that we can do folder and in this case
of this name is not very powerful I want
to consider a more powerful demon okay
homo neatest person so what I'm going to
do is just drop most of the conditions
okay on the product you so whenever I
have locations that occur at different
times lysis the condition I drop it okay
so I only keep the conditions that
involved locations at the same time so
in this case locations one and three and
in the same time is life so I have the
usual local it akan this one column okay
with some error so this i'm colleen
especially local stochastic this is a
business model okay
so the result is that well the X is 10
class plus of course have a property
called sing yourselves error correction
okay it's an sum of Prospero correction
that I will describe and quantum memory
is based on these skin turn out to
automatically be a resilient to this
kind of especially local a stochastic
noise okay so they have a narrow special
say we discussed late so that does the
main result i want to discuss and okay
so i will start describing a single
cetera correction and I have to start on
the beginning so what is our correct so
another correction we want to protect
the some logical qubit okay and we do
that by encoding them into a larger
diverse space we use many more physical
series to that in doing so we get many
extra degrees of freedom okay and we can
use this acceleration freedom to
construct to cooperate so these two
operators have some committing
observables that have some definite
value for encoding state and in a
seller's happens the value of disick
operators returns and we can use this
information to correct so in particular
other person proceeds as follows first
we measure all these two cooperators and
extract what is called the error
syndrome okay then we classically
compute or make a competition with this
error syndrome and decide which is the
error that is or the operation that is
more convenient to apply to in order to
correct okay and then we are back so
it's important to distinguish between
idea and a person and noisy error
correction so in the ideal case yes we
have some idea secretary that measures
the tickle craters then computes
classically and then apply some perator
to correct in the noisy case have to be
careful because now the secretary
measurements themselves are not reliable
and actually the error correction
procedure is very sensitive to such
errors so we don't want to see we don't
actually want to end up in through
similar or so we started with with
whether do something to make our
measurement more reliable setter for
example methane several okay and we will
need to measure more and more times as
we want to get more accurate so the
singles of our collection this thing is
appropriate is Franco's half is that it
is not a single round of Chico operator
machine so for this to be mathematically
meaningful i will ask that the whole
operation is a quantum local if I
quantum local I'm instance even
analogous to locc meaning that i'm
allowed local operation so finite this
quantum circuit and then arbitrary
classical competition so in the few
stages of our correction we have the
definitive instruction on the
correctional quantum so those would be
local operations and then the coziness
classical pseudo can be just some local
press
so you can already see that since error
correction is being performed in a
finite time somehow 10 correlative noise
will not play such a big drop right so
these are very prim it has to be useful
I useful approach to thank related much
now when introducing singular singles of
the resurrection I have many discussions
with colleagues about like okay what do
you mean by error correction like what
would qualify as error correction okay
and to try to answer that let me show
you this figure so you know we have some
want to memorize hands on the books and
computation and some process okay so we
will have some noisy process then we
apply error correction no you said a
correction so this is how we keep a
system kind of how we can show you how
we can keep it's a decision from failing
okay so it's kind of sad refrigeration
so I like to think in terms of
temperature okay so error correction of
some the figuration where we are
bringing the temperature down and errors
in this temperature so we have 19 the
system temperature goes up then if we
could apply IDL error correction we
would bring the temperature 20 it goes
up again and so on in the ID error
correction it's noisy so we cannot
achieve co temperature but there's some
finite temperature okay but in this
indicates of this single sort of a
person approach as the error correction
becomes less and less noisy you're
getting closer and closer to zero
temperature okay so in that sense it
approximate ivl error correction on that
that's what I'm in life ok so I think
this is also suggestive since you know
everything is all the temperature can be
very low somehow it seems that Dan
correlation should not great
and then there could be other approaches
to error correction but I'm not
discussing that today
so the code let's have these singers of
property are topological coach to
political calls for a closer to
political codes so many cultures way
into this racket eyes and they have
three main characteristics so the
physical qubits are placed on aleris
could be a two dimensional lattice like
this when a figure in the mission and so
on then importantly the check operators
are local so this means that we are
going to perform a service that only
involves if you do it in some
neighborhood ok and this from a
practical point of view it's been
important in this part of the reason why
these codes are popular the last
characteristic of the political code is
that they have something called local
missing disability so if I have some
loud flurries ok I don't depict the
killer but I have access only to some
region of the system that is a small
compared to assistance eyes then any
operator with support in that region
will not be able to tell me anything
about and contact information ok so
these are kind of the basic our case now
what I want to go to start with two
dimensional codes and show you why thank
you later noise will kill them ok and
then later we I will show like why I
think an original does not hold for this
cause with the singles of the origin
problem
so in two dimensions errors can be
visualized as having disabled strength
and the other symptoms confirmed to the
endpoints of this system so for example
here I have two decent surface there are
two boundaries and they have some Q is
here that suffers an ever so I can
visualize that some string and the film
for that error will correspond to so
will be some chick operators here that
lives in the bone in the end point of
attack or the testing ok so it is not
very important what will matter here is
that in order to keep this kind of cause
resistance without errors what we can do
is just keep track of where these
endpoints these particles as we like to
think of them ah ok so we just saw here
in depicting business placement picture
so one space and dimension and time goes
up and it is that we are going to
measure regularly the system and we call
the check operator are ok and this
engine area will be salty so here for
example so okay so this this watering
here's have the actual word line caused
by errors affecting the physical qubits
and the outcomes of the evidence of
stick operator measurements are depicted
here so these green ones are correct
outcomes this just one servo in this
case the result was that there was a
particle here but there is not in this
case here we didn't detect so the the
measurement didn't tell us that there
was a particle here but in actually they
were seduced or so forth and so on so if
we can keep track of particles in this
way well enough the system will not
suffer from the eclair
now I would like our them on to fool us
completely ok so to further limit to
have any certainty so that we don't see
absolutely nothing them coming out in
the system and the other than one is
able to introduce hello you color ok
with certainty or with high quality so
the kind of processes that the women
will consider are such as the one
depicted here so so if you money to move
so these are the system there to wonder
if you manage to move a particle from
end to end you will introduce a logical
error and you can do this step by step
by you know here I apply some some may
be a bit sleep or something I have to
physical commit they may create a
particle okay then I apply a no then I
if we measure okay but if there is a
fault of that measurement we will not
see any particle then we move out with a
Mon applies another or to move the
particle again so extending the string
again there should be a particular that
we will not detect it because of the
move will insult introduce a fault in
the same place okay so at every second
time in this process we have a single
fault okay and all you know we get a
logical error already in the entire of
the process so this in itself is not
that will not satisfy obviously so if we
just apply this is probably one it will
not satisfy the constraints of
especially local know it's bad what
women can do is so lambda 0 rate
remember so at every time step it's good
as dead included stars as the process is
probably Lana okay and this is Amanda so
you can see that for example this time
slice okay what is it provides you that
I have a fault here Nicole here will you
will be lambda square okay so it will
satisfy this especially locality
conditions and in fact it's a Markovian
process interesting
ah ok so this means that in you know
within some linear time in the system
size that memory will be damaged and in
fact this can be improved to make it a
finite so no matter how large the system
is it will take a final time to kill
calculate to let me tip floor demo and
we will not see anything happening okay
so I think this is pretty well okay so
it is possible to escape this kind of
tolerance and with single suit or
cracking codes and they come in two
flavors okay some of them require at
least four special dimensions and others
and work in three special image so let's
see have it hard works so in the 40 case
the key is that instead of having error
screen like errors now they are
membranes so the syndrome which
responsive on the other one degree of
the membranes are not unlike okay but
now it's going to be looked so I think
this is that if the lemon was trying to
use a similar strategy so remember he's
trying for us not to the text like
anything hot anyway so he is creating a
mess of here bang goes up again and he's
creating a membrane that is large enough
it becomes larger so here at this step
the demos has to hide all these symptom
here all the boundary right and he will
only be able to do that without
exponentially small probability then the
lemon could play with entropy and so on
but as possible to see that he will not
succeed ok so Portland a small enough
but small enough fellow right he will
never be able to introduce visibility
like
so that indicator is kind of more fun
because in this case error Sarah still
cling like Anderson them still take the
foreman of particles okay I'll just the
imprint of these strings and yet the
diamond cannot play so what will happen
now is that for something something
going to explain it is not enough so
remember the demos has to try through
much the fact of this article here
there's a political cancel before it was
enough in it to the case to introduce
our fault here okay right at the
measurement but now we will have to
introduce false connecting that particle
all the way down to the one area of the
system okay so because of these he will
again have some various majority allowed
to that okay so how much fun a
celebration and we will be say so
there's nothing you will not work so how
come is how it is possible well it
requires using substitution code so
insistent cause I said before that in a
narrow correcting code we are using
asparagus of freedom in order to
introduce the co-creators but what we
can also do is not use all their a
levels degrees of freedom and rather
reserved some maybe most of them as
so-called gates the case of you okay so
Gator gets off in emerges there is a
feel invincible we don't care a lot but
they're not to be very useful okay so
one way in which we can be useful is we
can measure them instead of the tech ok
it doesn't infer from this measurement
so let's have the gate so aggressive you
okay the gates degrees of freedom to
obtain some sort of gate syndrome and
from that gate syndrome infer what is
the errors in them okay so do it
indirectly and this is used so I want to
give a physical picture of how that is
useful so you know God's law he tell us
that the total amount of charge in some
region of space is directly related to
the flags of the corresponding field
through the boundary of this especially
okay
so in the course of half three singers
of property which have the gate code
code chart or church or the whole server
display like error syndrome ok so this
early these particles and the doll of
the field display when against if
negation so now instead of measuring
directly they start we are going to
measure the field I'm from the field in
fair wear whatever charges we can do
that through the ghazal right but with
that here's what will happen based on
green and give me here dimensional
picture so suppose that the demo want to
fake the amount of starts in this point
okay so i can draw many regions like
that okay and if the service is going to
be different this means that for any
each of these surfaces okay or like
boundaries i will need to have some fake
elect a field going through that that
boundary during right so this will be
true for anyone so the thing is that i
need to introduce or the memo need to
introduce some fake flux of a hilt okay
connecting the particle or charge to the
boundary opposition
so that's kind of the trick silly how
much things are open so just to give you
any person of how it works in in
practice into the gauge color code so
this call satisfying on a simplicial
lettuce cubits leave in the synthesis
okay in the Sahara and then the color of
Elvis's and color links the checkup is
of course on to the birth pieces ok so
these are attributable sex we could have
a particular or not and they are color
and the gate operators okay so we are
going to to measure to the communication
don't correspond to links and they are
also color so without may be going into
details or maybe I can go into some
detail so there is that well although
whenever I have an odd number so given
any color combination if i have enough
number of links of sites are color and
in at the vertex then forgiven like a
syndrome then that will be have another
teresa another's intimate at work okay
so there is this kind of relationship
that is the same as in the as in the
case of electrical charge and other
items because here there is an
underlying also gauge in theory that i
will not talk about right
so I like to emphasize that would this
have been here some sort of confinement
okay so in these two dimensional code
there is a big difference between
measuring the co-operators or measuring
gates operator so if I just go ahead and
message directly recuperator now so the
venom can very easily introduce say two
particles that are far away which is
kind of damaging so the cost for him to
fake measurements here is as lambda
square theta is just to locations on the
other hand if we measure gates operators
for the able to fake two charges it will
know to introduce false all along the
flux lines connecting these two guys
okay so as the distance between these
charges increases the probability for
sort of thing will decrease
exponentially okay we do this and that
I'm calling confinement I think it's
pretty fair
good
so finally let me be a bit more precise
about what is the result in the paper so
I consider in just quantum memories okay
and so that's ice before so I quantum
memory would be yes concatenation of
check some noise another correction now
a sort of correction and so on so we are
not doing anything no computation at all
I'm not have to evaluate how good the
memories we just sang with the whole
process between a perfect and colima
perfect the call in and ask okay how
close is the total process to the
identity okay so particular for the
noisy part i just have in the AVL case
the identity apply to HQ it and then the
usual like a special local knowledge
with some error rate lambda okay and for
the noisy error correction turns out
that qualitatively is enough to consider
measurement errors okay so I again have
like a special local constraints from
them for some other parameter ETA okay
so I saw these two parameters and now I
guess concatenate you know some
correction any number of times three and
the result is that as long as the other
is London it are small enough the
probability that this whole thing will
will will introduce an error is smaller
than this where a and B are both
exponentially to press a scientist
decision okay so just what you with
respect
alright so with that I wrap up so okay I
haven't said anything about computation
but the interview gets cooler coats
basically all the gates are transversal
with the Cabot that you need to do some
kind of error correction operations but
they all can be done this kind of single
subway so I don't respect any
difficulties in achieving universal
computation so this kind of skin for
this kind of noise then I think an
interesting issue is whether we believe
the three spatial dimensions so for
localized Oh Cassidy's knowledge there
is no such a constrain our
dimensionality so even in one dimension
you can do alternates with a bronze so
it's interesting in this case for this
kind of tranquilizer noise is this a
setback of strangers has to do with
dimension specimens and pal another
importantly problem is what happens when
I do not know where my publication
process included is having a very
different kind of problem that of course
will have a different kind of solution
and well I said before that the other
person assigned considering uses global
classical operations or what happens if
I two signatures to local competition to
some sort of cellular automaton based
error correction and some in the most
interesting this is the most amazing
thing is what is the physics of silica
gel coats okay so if I construct
Hamiltonians related to them what kind
of face is going to get and what made
most importantly is it possible to
recover some sort of confinement with
some sort of generalization of this of
this kuroko's yeah thank you
[Applause]
Thank You Hector we have time for some
questions
hi Hector so at one point you said
something like topological code to the
kind of codes where we see single-shot
error correction oh no no I know I
didn't mean that economies that remark I
mean that no yes the thing is are the
references are they know I'm topological
yes so the follow-up is have you made
any progress thinking what non
topological constructions as codes to
the single-shot encryption might exist
as you see if I were saying no is there
any indication of how you might do it in
a way that's not stop illogical I some
LDPC codes or something well you mean if
you could do similar things within the
difficult years I think Lee but I have
not thought about it like if it is like
really in the sink in a powerful way no
I don't know
are there more question
um in in some cases even if there isn't
intrinsically time correlated noise you
you it might be possible to have an
effective description where time
correlations appears so in topological
codes I'm not sure if the same sort of
thing would rise but in in some things
I've looked at if you're doing say Steen
syndrome extraction in a regular CSS
code rather than treating the
measurements as as being as having
errors you can effectively commute those
errors out of the the syndrome
extraction circuit and they become
correlated errors that happen before and
after the circuit so in a case like that
you you've got a picture that where
suddenly time correlation has appeared
in your in your noise model but you know
what kind of time correlations you would
expect in a case like that so if you
have some knowledge of what type of time
correlation you you know are allowed and
then other ones are considered who's
still forbidden presumably that would
give you greater power and being able to
correct hairs no absolutely and I mean
the things that the kind of blank
relatedness that will appear effectively
indicates will be weakly correlated
right so it's kind of quality totally
different so I guess I was trying to
answer i defending kind of a different
kind of curiosity because from practical
perspective some kind of amazing or
effective tank relations items in there
so damaging
thank you so do you know if a single
shot error correction necessarily has a
negative impact on either the threshold
or the overhead so do you have estimates
for the threshold I have no nothing like
that
so if there are no more question let's
thank Hector and all the speaker of this
session
[Applause]